ici la pression augmente depuis des
années tellement que l'urgence de
Maisonneuve-Rosemont fait face à une
possible rupture de service
j'espère qu'ils vont prendre
notre cœur c'est un
ultimatum environ 90 des 110 infirmières
menacent de démissionner elles ont signé
une pétition dans laquelle elle exigent
le départ immédiat de leur chef parce
qu'ici le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire ou non est devenu trop
important je crois que on devrait fermer
l'urgence pour quelques jours pour faire
état de la situation de crise avec
l'équipe toutes les équipes
l'établissement explique que l'urgence
de maison de Rosemont reçoit
quotidiennement jusqu'à 25% plus de
patients que sa capacité alors quand
vous regardez l'urgence de maison
neuve-rosemont je les comprends d'être
découragé parce que c'est comme une roue
sans fin il y a trop de volume dimanche
le ministre admettait que maison
neuve-rosemont est devenue beaucoup trop
petit et estimait que l'établissement
devrait imiter d'autres hôpitaux et
changer sa gestion des horaires mais le
syndicat pense que ça ne règle pas le
problème de fond il nous manque du monde
c'est ça le problème principal c'est pas
des choses comme l'autogestion des
horaires qui a été suggéré par le
ministre hier soir à Tout le monde en
parle qui vont changer quoi que ce soit
ça Québec solidaire pense que le
gouvernement a largué l'hôpital et tout
l'est de Montréal la gestion locale font
ce qu'ils peuvent avec ce qu'ils ont
le ministre par contre est aux abonnés
absents la CAC abandonné les oeuf de
Montréal le ministre a abandonné
l'Hôpital Maisonneuve-Rosemont cette
nouvelle affaire risque de compliquer
encore plus le recrutement de personnel
les infirmières qui ont l'embarras du
choix risque de ne pas être attiré par
cette établissement qui vit des crises à
répétition ici David Canada Montréal